hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcast I'm Cameron and
today I'm going to talk to you about
three ways that you can get work as a
remote freelancer
[Music]
hey there and welcome to the video
podcasts like I said I'm Cameron you
know that if you've been following the
channel for any amount of time I'm the
guy here talking about all things motion
graphics motion design related great to
have you here like I said today I want
to talk about three ways that you can
get work as a remote freelancer it's
easier than you think to get work as a
remote freelancer and I've got three
simple ways to do it there's always you
know a thousand ways to skin a cat or
whatever the saying is at the moment but
I'm just going to give you three simple
ways number one go to a website called
working not working okay it's just one
of many websites out there that you can
go you can scour the pages you typically
have to set up an account and you can
apply for jobs that are being posted you
can put yourself out there
put your reel out there and just get
noticed you just need to get online and
get noticed working not working is a
great place for you to go to get motion
design work a place you don't want to go
that's like working not working but you
don't want to go there as a motion
designer in my opinion is a site like up
work okay a site like up work is great
for different types of freelancers like
writers it seems to be really great for
writers it's really great for like
social media strategist things like
people like that occupations like that
it's not so great for motion graphic
artists and editors what I've seen is
that you're not going to get the rates
that you deserve on sites like that on
sites like upwork so typically stay away
from sites like up work go to sites like
working not working it's really cool too
because working out working you
essentially can mark your status as hey
I'm working or I'm not working I'm
available I'm on vacation whatever it is
it's a great site check it out
number two Facebook groups okay go to
Facebook
type in a search for motion design
motion graphics you're gonna get a lot
of different pages and groups related to
motion design now inside these groups
you can just you can go in there you
need to start interacting in discussions
you need to give your opinions people
are asking questions about hey how do I
do this or what do you think of this
here's a link to my reel get involved in
the motion design motion graphics
community and interact and let people
know who you are once you start
interacting people are gonna ask like
hey what do you do what what's you know
can we see your work things like that
post your real don't jump into a group
and immediately just throw your real out
there and say hey looking for work what
do you guys think you know it it's it's
okay if you're gonna do that but I
wouldn't necessarily recommend it it
does put some people off and they're
thinking that hey maybe you're not there
to give you just want to get and if
that's the case they may not help you
out but there's a lot of Facebook groups
out there I'm not going to name the ones
that I've seen because there's so many
of them but just join some groups the
bigger ones are typically better because
there's a lot more people involved your
reel is gonna get passed around a little
bit more but just join a Facebook group
and you'd be surprised what happens when
you put your reel out there number three
ads okay this is the one's gonna cost
you some money but Facebook ads
Instagram ads you've seen them they get
put in your feet all the time they work
okay
they're cheap at least right now they're
cheap to do and they work I'm not gonna
break down how do you go about creating
a Facebook ad there's a lot of YouTube
videos out there to kind of show you
like the rough steps to take and the
truth of the matter is I've been doing
Facebook ads for a long time and it's
constantly changing the interface for
Facebook is constantly changing so I'm
going to tell you how to do it one way
today and tomorrow you're gonna watch
this video and it's going to be
completely different okay it's really
fairly simple how to navigate the site
but you just have to have a Facebook
page
you're going to go in you're gonna put
your real in the ad okay the ad is your
real so that when someone sees that
they're gonna click play and they're
gonna watch your real your headlines
gonna be you know something along the
lines of like freelance or remote
freelancer or motion design freelancer
whatever you let people know in that
headline that you're a remote freelancer
and then like I said your real is the
video and then you're gonna have a
button down there and that buttons gonna
be like learn more book now that kind of
thing and that button is going to lead
to your website and so they're gonna
click that button based on so you you
spend a little bit money it goes out to
people that you select which is awesome
because you can say hey I work in this
country I only want to work in this
country limit my ad to this country or
limit my ad if like me for the u.s. I
would limit my ad to certain cities
within the US so for me if I want to
work for production studios I'm gonna
target my ad to production studios in
Los Angeles in Seattle in New York City
in Chicago and Atlanta that kind of
thing those type of places my ads gonna
be targeted very specifically to studios
and those cities and probably like the
creative director and the ad will lead
to leads right so if a company sees your
at your real they see your ad this your
real maybe they don't book you
immediately but you just popped up on
the radar if they really like your work
and your real it's going to lead to some
potential work in the future so that's
what I got for you that's three easy
ways to get work as a remote freelancer
today working not working Facebook
groups and pages and paid Facebook ads
and Instagram ads three simple ways to
get work as a freelancer I hope I helped
you out some simple way today until next
time I'm Cameron and this is motion sign
[Music]